he was like you're gonna be naked
tonight and I was like whatever you say
Daddy whatever daddy said Megan Fox
isn't one to shy away from a little
flirty banter with her fiance Machine
Gun Kelly this is what it's all about
now the actress is back at it sliding
into her man's insta comments with one
sexy request get her pregnant wow on
Tuesday MGK attended the time 100 next
Gala rocking skin tight black latex
pants a see-through corset top and black
latex sleeves with gloves and Meg she
was right by his side absolutely slaying
in this metallic copper colored
strapless gown with a thigh-high slit I
think that looks great the next day the
musician shared a few snaps from the
event referencing The Game of Thrones
prequel series House of the Dragon in
the caption quote I came for the
Targaryen BDSM party I personally
enjoyed it others may not have the same
experience and Meg was clearly a fan of
the Bloody Valentine singer's look
writing quotes never has anyone with
better bone structure walked this Earth
exquisitely devastatingly handsome and
six foot five kill me or get me pregnant
those are the only options
yep you heard that right she said get me
pregnant love is probably the biggest
project I've ever worked on yeah so yeah
everything encompassing that I put you
know I I give that more energy than I
give my work of course MGK has a 13 year
old daughter Cassie from a previous
relationship while Megan shares three
children ten-year-old Noah
eight-year-old Bodhi and six-year-old
Journey with her ex Brian Austin Green
Brian and his girlfriend Sharna Burgess
welcomed a son Zane back in June
[Music]
Zayn is awesome sharn is amazing she's
an amazing mom I have five kids we joke
about the fact that I had a
I already had a station wagon if I have
another one
um then I'm moving to like a school bus
or something and A source told E.T
earlier this month that Megan MGK Brian
and Sharna are all cordial adding that
Megan and Brian have a healthy
co-parenting relationship as for Megan
and MGK another source told E.T they are
open to potentially expanding their
family one day they are doing so amazing
as a couple and they pretty much worship
the ground that each other walks on and
when it comes to wedding planning
back in July A source told us Megan and
MGK are pretty much done wedding
planning they are both totally on the
same page which has made things easy for
them we don't know what's happening both
are very tight lips about we just
honestly don't know yet like he's on
tour this year so we're just playing it
by ear and then when it when it needs to
happen it'll open up the universe will
open it up and we'll do it
[Music]